Roy it's absolutely lovely to see you
today at collector mania we love your
work and the audiobooks for Game of
Thrones and on the show as well what was
it like bringing George RR Martin's work
to life in those audiobooks well that
was in I mean I think I've done five so
far and they've all been very successful
will the series is made out of them and
how made they're done in the series now
three isn't it
three so that's still two more to go and
George's tells me he's got another one
nearly ready so that'll be at least a
few more years work anyway but I enjoy
doing it I what was interesting I had to
find voices for so many different
characters you know I think in Episode
three I had to buy and find voices 240
different characters and in Episode five
I had five voices for three hundred and
ten different characters so I was
beginning to run short of nationalities
after more I mean how do you go about
creating all of those different voices
and remembering them as well
yeah well I didn't always remember them
I had to make out a list in alphabetical
order of all the characters I John I
think I finished up with 17 full scape
pages of all the different characters
and I'd say oh wait a minute
have I done that one before no I don't
ease when I needed up and find a had
done it before and you know I was using
a whatever kind of action was required
for the part which are your favorite
voices that you do can you give us a
little taste of them III there was a
very gentle character though that he
talked right there like that and he was
very extremely old and and very very
sensitive and extremely a sweet man I
quite liked him I've forgotten his name
now there's so many how did you find
doing Ygritte as well as the female
characters like you know nothing Jon
Snow the female characters I didn't make
any attempts at the female characters I
had to play this very street you know
with a high-pitched voice of course but
you know I couldn't make any chance of
doing theme
characters do you keep in touch with
George about what he's doing
yeah as a matter of fact on my what was
it my 90th birthday he he came to New
York soon after York to Los Angeles he
came up from the inner deep south where
he lives and spent a couple of days of
me and in Los Angeles and he he came to
a party we had on my birthday night and
they he was great fun
so we enjoyed it tremendously and I hope
you know that he's working on a another
episode now and we should be able to
record it soon look forward to that
definitely and of course you've been in
the TV show as well haven't you what did
you enjoy about your character on that
yeah well I was supposed to be in I'm
supposed to have a leading role in the
series but unfortunately I got cancer
and I had to go into a hospital and have
all kinds of operations and things well
are totally cured of it now totally
cured so but you know they they didn't
have the part they could find for me so
I played what's his name yeah Pyromancer
yeah whatever that is
yeah he am so yeah at least I was in it
and they promised that when they find
the right part I can come back and do
something else we'd love to see that and
one of our views is wondering whether
you still keep in touch with one poem
and who you worked with so memorably on
the Hellboy 2 and also Beauty and the
Beast that's true yes and cuz you know I
worked with Ron Perlman on not only on
Hellboy but he's such a great actor run
and we did the Beauty and the Beast
together for many years
and I still see a lot of him he we have
lunch most most Fridays at
a little restroom we know in in Las in
Los Angeles I'm going back to Los
Angeles I have to go back in December
but some I do know for how long this
time
and finally what would you like to say
to the fans out there that you've made
throughout your career and especially
from the Game of Thrones audiobooks and
your part in the show they are amazing
they really are they aren't true friends
because you know they've support you and
just evidence of that today this cure a
mile long for autographs known and there
there's nice people there such they're
so pleasant and and flattering because
I'm I think my efforts are just fairly
ordinary but they make themselves if
they're extraordinary she'll by a while
you're very sweet and the fans I love
them I love them
you